throughout the election campaign
Nicholas sturgeons message could not
have been more clear the SNP will never
put the Tories into government not now
not ever we will not do any deals that
were put the Tories into power which is
why coming on the day she attacked the
Tories but an anti Trident rallying
Glasgow a leaked memo suggesting she
told the French ambassador she wanted Mr
Cameron to remain as Prime Minister was
so explosive now seven weeks later and
after a Whitehall leak inquiry the
former Scotland Secretary the Liberal
Democrat MP Alistair Carmichael has
admitted he was responsible and
apologized to her I've accepted full
responsibility for what happened here
this happened in my department involved
my special adviser while I was a
secretary of state for scotland i could
have stopped her she'd have stopped and
I was clearly an error of judgment on my
part further I have apologized both to
the First Minister and to the French
ambassador the First Minister whose
party 156 MPs in the election so she's
grateful for an apology that is not
going to let the matter rest I'm saying
he should consider his possession and
reflect on the fact that you know he
didn't put his hands up to this during
the election I'm a politician that spent
my whole political career campaigning
against conservatives and conservative
government the idea that I wanted to see
another tory government is absurd when
the leak Rao erupted over the Easter
weekend Alistair Carmichael said this is
the middle of an election campaign these
things happen Nicola Sturgeon responded
by accusing him of dirty tricks and a
smear campaign despite the First
Minister's denials it's still not
entirely clear whether the leaked memo
written by mr. Carmichael's special
adviser was accurate or not a Cabinet
Office statement said the cabinet
secretary has concluded that there's no
reason to doubt that he recorded
accurately what he thought he'd heard
but in his letter to the First Minister
mr. Carmichael said
I accept that its publication was a
serious breach of protocol and that the
details of that account are not correct
the Cabinet Office says part of Miss
sturgeons conversation might have been
lost in translation it was reported to a
civil servant by the French Consul
General in Edinburgh I do not know where
this comes from because it is certainly
not in my report that anyone made any
pref early to give any preference after
ms Sturgeon met Mr Cameron in Edinburgh
last week she described their talks as
constructive and businesslike no mention
of friendly or cordial suggesting the
leaked by one of mr. Cameron's coalition
ministers has left a bitter taste John
Craig Sky News